pembrokeshire west wales
covered rates here are amongst the
lowest in the country
but the same tough lockdown will still
apply
at the butchers in narbeth customers are
getting ready
to stay at home this is better for me to
stay in
that's why i've been in about all my
meet now so i'm gonna come out to report
that
so you stocked up knowing that you're
gonna be in for two weeks yes
and i'm going to feel safe frustrating
um i mean it's i'm a grad anyway so it's
frustrating time at the moment anyway
but it just means
life is stopping again for another two
three weeks if it is two weeks
i can see there's obviously less cases
down here um
so compared to the rest of whales anyway
but then we've also got smaller
hospitals so you don't want to put the
strain on them as well
in the week to october the 15th
pembrokeshire had a coveted case rate
of 37 per 100 000. compare that to
cardiff
at 288 but the welsh government
says those numbers are rising the first
minister says this lockdown will only
work if
everyone plays their part wherever they
live
however low the covered numbers may be
in certain areas
that is frustrating for some who would
prefer to see
a tiered system
stephen lowe maintains boats in tenbis
harbour
for him keeping local lockdowns would be
better
i'd rather see a tiered system for this
area
with very low numbers here in tembe
and we were very very busy in the summer
the beaches were completely packed and
there's a lot of people around everyone
thought that that would bring the
affection down here but it doesn't seem
to be the case
wells lockdown covers half term which
usually helps tourism businesses
get through the winter after an already
bad season
that cash has also now been taken away
it's usually quite a busy week so it's
the last
busy week of the year but so it will
impact
all businesses and tell me because there
will be nobody here
so it's just hoping that the weather
stays fine and people
do that live here do come out and
support local businesses
when the lockdown ends on november the
9th a new set of national rules
will come into force the country-wide
approach in wales
will continue far beyond the fire break
dan whitehead sky news
in pembrokeshire